the king of speed chess strikes again
Hikaru Nakamura saw no signs of slowing
down in his match against the young and
talented alireza faruja Ali Reza may
have taken an early lead to start but
never count Hikaru out in the blink of
an eye alireza blundered this position
allowing Hikaru to instantaneously
Checkmate main one we're gonna have an
ending that oh Rook f8
checkmate
and in a very bizarre situation Hikaru
checkmated alireza's Queen in this game
but black can't move in fact let's check
me to the queen they call the speed of
Hikaru Nakamura impressive is an
understatement and at the end of the
match the Karu carved his victory with
four consecutive wins bro thinks he's
Hikaru because